but is that a fair is that a fair
characterization of you yeah have you
like actually general I spent hours
brainstorming with you before I feel
like for you to get excited about
building something it's got to start
with some emotion like either you think
of something that makes you laugh and
then you're just giggling and but you're
serious about it once you start laughing
or is something like really sad story
and you're like okay this is an
injustice in the world I want a good
song but is that a fair is that a fair
characterization of you yeah I mean I do
like things that kind of go viral and
like for me you probably need a haircut
I mean I was I told my girlfriend I was
like I'm a hundred percent sure this is
gonna go viral and she's like well how
do you know how do you know and I was
like well like the name and and kind of
you know we're Brad and it was the
timing like you just see it with a
couple of journalists and you know throw
it up on product hunt and like before
you know it like I don't know he
probably had a hundred and fifty
thousand uniques in the first 24 hours
how many actual haircuts probably more
probably over a thousand at this point
yeah yeah definitely more than we have
money Silas you did 200 so yeah more now
any public speaking thing where they
like hey can you send me like your bio
this absolutely needs to be the first
thing you know I you know conducted I'm
responsible for over hundred thousand
and the crazy thing is that people like
actually look good like I because you
don't have a haircut right now you're
growing it out the crazy try booking a
haircut right like this weekend weekend
if the site is busy now I'm an
entrepreneurial I'm out here I gotta say
I got a make it happy for the people I
love it there's a reason I have this hat
on because you know your boy butchered
himself with his own 2:00 a.m. haircut
with his own
without using your website and you can't
do my hair so that's why
[Music]